now what's going on
uh where's that endpoint so i guess i'm
going to make we call this zebra
moving across
here okay right now which to me by my
numbers uh i guess we'll set our scale
over here is like
60 so that makes
uh i can't do distances
okay let's call this
that's pretty close is that right
so that makes 10
20
okay
least consistent scale level it'll have
to do all right now what's happening
okay let's actually do this i don't know
if i'm going to draw trains
um they both start
at time zero at the origin okay after
one second
get on henry he pulls forward five years
okay so
here we go
one second okay
after the same second has elapsed
thomas is right in front right
13.9 so that's like i don't know that's
15 right so it's definitely
something like that
okay
say
this is actually really heavy because
they're out of bed
so okay now this matches up with what we
looked at before right which was that
thomas starts out much quicker and buy a
lot right that's why he shoots off okay
what happens is things progress well
we're done henry close forward number
five so there he is at 10.
now after the next fight we get up to
22.
now after um after two seconds right it
looks like
thomas kind of has this in the back
right yes it's incredible but as things
progress what's going to happen
another second passes you're up to t
comes three now and now thomas hasn't
even moved past 30 right and you can see
the rest of the numbers
um he spawned down pretty bad i don't
know
too much something um 32.2
is not nearly as far ahead as it was
before you can literally see the gap
closing right if we fast forward a bit
let's go all the way up to say
46 and 45.
that's that's 45.
okay so at this point they are neck and
neck right
can you hear the music
yeah i know i i watch a lot of thomas
these days because my son is like two
and a half sure and he's like go on
thomas
the distance between this crazy
obviously and you can see
it's the next second because obviously
heavy's just gonna keep on chugging at
his five meters per second the next
second is the crucial one that we're
interested in okay but before we do that
to actually answer the question
can you now see the relevance of this
equation
right
so in fact that's what i'd like you to
put as your thoughts right
i'd like you to write down here okay
what's useful here in solving this
question
is this difference right
thomas is displacement minus henry's now
i suppose a difference you know if i
flip it around it's still going to be a
difference but magnitude is still going
to be same why would i put thomas's
value first and then subtract enemies
why would i do it that way
yeah because thomas started out in front
right so thomas minus henry makes sense
for most of this right so let's actually
get some values here right
zero
uh
8.9
12
20
uh sorry 12 point
look at the number
10.8
8.9
6.6
3.9
1.1
okay
now there's my values so far right
they're nice and easy to do because then
now what happens as we transition from t
equals nine to ten equals ten
right
well
it's gonna be 48 minus 50 right so now
you get -2
and then you'll get minus
5.3 yes
so what's going on we're going to try to
oh something
right but it resists nice neat like
exact solutions that's why you have to
use your calculator you should
mechanically bash out the numbers okay
but what you actually see happening
right and when you do oh let's go i'm
sorry
no when you do this right you can see
the the significance of the negative
number okay because you can pop this
into your calculator and you can get the
numbers but you don't necessarily know
what it means at t equals 10
when henry
gets up to 50.
okay and thomas is
behind him now for the first
when you're actually going about solving
this you have to see what's going on
right maybe you graph it maybe you don't
right by the way can you see we ought to
have expected this kind of behavior
because
thomas's displacement
is governed by a log function right
which is a thing that slows down right
so this is actually like a decay
situation
so what's the actual question today
it says
um
find during which second
the trains are level
and then we'll move on to the speed okay
now you have to be careful because that
language of during which second
is kind of different to this right
during which second is a um
it's a it's an average thing whereas
this is a precise instantaneous thing
right
so what does t equals one what does that
mean
it means at the end of the first second
right so this this spot in between here
right or maybe i should put
something like that
that's the first second
so that makes this the second second
and the third one and the fourth and so
on so where does the transition happen
it happens in
here right
in that second okay which between is
between nine and ten so that means
okay
so this is your answer
how are you going to answer the second
part i
find the speed at which the chains are
drawing apart at the end of this setting
so
not to get into um relativity or
anything like that all we're going to
look at is the difference in their
velocities okay so take t equals 10
that's at the end of this second right
take t equals 10 and you're going to be
substituting into the two velocity
functions right
so i guess you're going to get
20 on 11
right
and
this is still five because it's
independent of time right so if you want
the speed let's get drawing a part
what are you going to calculate
which one's bigger
five is bigger right henry just keep
that's why it's lost right so you know
five minus twenty one eleven which i
think from memory is three and two
elevenths
okay me just pushed me
since it's a speed you don't say it's
negative right it's just a it's just a
scalar it's just a quantity of value
all right now last question
when is henry furthest behind thomas and
by how much
and now you can see actually was
actually kind of valuable for us to put
out this table because you can see
thomas
starts out he gets a leak then because
he slows down that lead diminishes right
so which second is thomas most in the
lead jury
and the answer is
better than saying t equals three is
during the third second okay because
it's somewhere in here you don't
actually know between 2.0 and 12.7 it
could be a max right it could be an
actual station i assume there is
right is it actually is that right there
yeah so
they asked you
when is
and by how much to the nearest meter
well since we calculated it to one
decimal place i guess we would take 13
meters